كيف تصف لنا اليوم الوضع الانساني
والاجتماعي في رفح حتى
الساعه جلال ربما هو في اصعب حالاته خاصه
ان النازحون مستمرون في القدوم الى مدينه
رفح هذه الم هذه المدينه التي باتت مكتظه
عن بكره ابيها الناس على الطرقات الناس في
الشوارع الناس في الخيام على قرب الحدود
المصريه وليله امس كان هناك ايضا غاره
اسرائيليه على هذه الحدود ومنذ يومين ايضا
كانت هناك مزيد من الغارات الاسرائيليه
على هذه الحدود تستهدف اراض زراعيه في تلك
المناطق وبالتالي رغم ان هذا المكان ايضا
مكتظ بالنازحين الفلسطينيين ونصبت مئات
بالالف من الخيام في تلك المناطق الا ان
الغارات ما زالت مستمره على تلك المناطق
مدينه رفح تواجه ربما صعوبه ايضا في
استقبال هؤلاء المرضى وهؤلاء المراجعين
نحن امام مستشفى الكويت التخصصي وكما ترى
هناك ازدحام كبير على هذا المستشفى الذي
كان يستقبل قبل الحرب نحو 40 الى 50 حاله
من المرضى في مدينه رفح التي كان يقدر
تعداد سكانها بنحو 300000 نسمه اليوم
مليون و300 ال نسمه وهؤلاء جزء منها جزء
منهم كبير من النازحين الذين اتوا للعلاج
وبالتالي اليوم هذه المستشفى تستقبل 1500
حاله ولك ان تتخيل هذه مستشفى صغيره 700
متر على 700 متر اقيمت وليس فيها كل
التخصصات ولكن رغم كل ذلك هي تحاول قدر
الامكان استيعاب هذا العدد الكبير ودائما
هناك ازدحام وبالتالي نصبت هذه الخيام في
على بوابه المستشفى احدى هذه الخيام خاصه
بالنساء احداها خاصه بالاطفال الاطفال هم
ربما الاكثر عرضه للامراض و شاهدنا وا
استطلعنا من الاطباء هنا ان عدد الاطباء
عدد المرضى من الاطفال يقدر ب 500 حاله اي
انهم ثلث المرضى الذين يصلون الى المستشفى
هم من الاطفال ما بين امراض معديه وامراض
جلديه وامراض معويه يعانون من جراء البرد
القارس يعانون من جراء انتقال العدوى في
المخيمات التي يقيمون فيها مخيمات نصبت
للنازحين وبسبب الاكتظاظ وبسبب ايضا قله
البنيه التحتيه البنيه التحتيه لا ل لا
تحتمل هذا العدد الكبير في رفح وبالتالي
هناك معاناه كبيره لدى الطاقم الصحي ولدى
المؤسسات الصحيه والطبيه في مدينه رفح من
جراء هذا الاكتضاض في السكان بالاضافه الى
ان مدينه رفح لم ت لا ت ستطيع الان
استيعاب اعداد مزيد اعداد اكثر من هؤلاء
النازحين الذين استوعبته خلال الايام
والاشهر ماضيه من جراء استمرار الحرب
الاسرائيليه شكرا لكما هشام في رفح